[Music]
last week it was made clear that johnny
depp and warner brothers will go their
separate ways in the future due to the
abuse allegations against his ex-wife
amber heard
meaning that he will no longer be the
actor of the evil wizard grindelwald
financially however this should not
bother him at all as he will still
receive his eight-figure salary
fans reacted mixedly to deb's retirement
on the one hand many fans jump to the
popular active side and criticize warner
brothers
on the other hand others see the
situation a bit more pragmatically and
wonder
who will succeed him if one believes the
magazine deadline there's already a
clear favorite
casino royal villain mats mikkelsen
although nothing has been decided yet
mikkelsen is probably considered the
favorite of director david yates
but they shouldn't take too much time
either because the production of
fantastic beasts 3
is already in progress should mickelson
be engaged
one can strongly assume that he'll also
play the wizard gellert grindelwald in
the planned parts 4 and 5
of the fantastic beasts series the us
release of the third part is expected to
be on july 15
2022
[Music]
you